you know welcome to this video I'm
slightly different video I'm compared to
all the Blitz videos I did recently this
is a blitz cute thing and um the reason
I'm doing this is that um should look at
the black player here this is Grand
Master with the handle raffaello he's
some played quite a lot of games on monk
play chess calm the server by chessbase
and they also it's active on the asus
eee but rubber rally I mean as you see
the rating is exceptionally high in in
blitz three-minute blitzes it is mostly
here here it is 31 so a slight increment
and they have been huge discussion some
about the identity of this player not
quite sure um if it is really clear who
that is but it's a very very good player
for some also a big rumor that it's
Kasparov but well you don't know you
cannot really tell the only thing that
is clear on that it's really a human I
mean they checked but with ICC and play
chess check that this is no computer so
um get us enjoy some games I hope he's
on for quite a while and we have a groom
felt hear that term is some technical
position now simplified to an end game
where material is equal if i'm not
mistaken yeah it is equal um need to
adjust to all this year and yeah black
is some in slight trouble he's got this
week see porn on c7
and why just got the king on d3 so a big
space advantage yeah now black at least
got the edge porn but the edge porn is
not easy to use the app black tries to
use some the King King Gandhi 72 to
cover the sea poem
yeah like has managed to do to get the
king in 27 yeah what is what does sound
like supposed to do it's not not a nice
position the thing that I want to
address I'm quite often none that's the
rumor that some of those Russian
accounts I actually not used by one
player but by a couple of players they
simply m they shared the account which
is not really according to ICC rules but
yeah five a break yeah blackest black is
in some trouble it's hard to give him
some advice now I may be the threat is e
6 yeah that's some talk that this might
be a kayaking yeah it's possible with
them there's no no clear evidence yeah
this now looks bad for black really the
f porn seems to fall and then white yeah
or now d5 and term white can push f4 f5
and then it's got the free porns
yeah maybe black slipped out of this
it's a very complicated but still it's
still dangerous with those phones I
thought the h4 mad what can just go
rooty to now yeah all this one stopping
the porn with seven seconds on the clock
you cannot defend this and by the way so
by the way the white play I completely
forgot about the white player this is
grand master Eduardo main from on
something similar my french
pronunciation as leg and dairy bed it's
a French Grand Master of about slightly
below 2700 and we actually got a drawn
endgame now the C porn is enough to draw
really an astounding that like I managed
to to save the game with just a couple
of seconds on the clock but this is
sometimes the beauty of increment you
will get a miraculous safe this will
certainly get lost at some point I'm not
quite sure that I'm yeah now i'm
following so black here the french
player with the French flag also is it
while romain de he's slightly below 2700
s mansion so very good opponent earphone
raffaello whatever this might be yeah
this is the real line of the French
defense played by the French player here
on this Queen a 52 a for this is
sometimes called the portage hook
variation or hookah portage variation
and sometimes also called the black
queen blues um interesting line where
black chem early on gets the Queen to a
four to initiate exactly this maneuver
b6 be sure basics it just looks very
nice from a strategic point of view to
get rid of the light squared create the
bishops but the problem is exactly what
what you see on the board now
the dark squares from of black are weak
without the bishop and why just got them
and go to technical challenges against
this King on f8 for example a move like
h6 is very ugly if yeah this is why
black played h6 not a nag age 6 is very
ugly to face because some after h6 g6
the light squares are very weak I had
the dark squares a very weak and now
probably Rugare 3 and black needs to go
back to age with the king it's not them
yeah it's not nice um I personally never
would play this is black and simply a.m.
would get too nervous with with the King
running around all the time
yeah grant masters heroin suggests in
the kibbutz thing to take the e cig
spawn yeah this was certainly possible
sacrificing the peace the white player
is some just trying to provoke
weaknesses with them with peace threats
and he takes this time it's not it's not
hurrying too much relying on the fact
that at the end that's the one second
increment that might save him enum in
technical position so we can really
finish the game it's difficult however
to give white some direct advice how to
how to get how to increase the pressure
on the King side it's it's difficult
he's got the Queen on g4 and look on f3
end but it doesn't really threaten so
much Queen f1 I am not sure what this
really am leads to win f1 bishop you one
young maybe just bag okay interesting
and now opening up yeah I think black is
probably in good shape here it's not
clear what what rights pieces are doing
on the kingside he's got it all defended
and black Scott play on the sea island
has this um this Queen invaded on f1
this is some can be potentially very
nice but down the queen is also in some
danger to to your truck maybe but at the
moment there's just D for hanging how
does a wide protected I don't turn don't
see at the moon yeah he's trying for
four count to play
try for counter play on on the king but
the black gown can just go nite fh maybe
let fh to you six sound it looks good
you know
yup like I said probably winning but
it's still found a fairly complicated
yeah 96 that's probably just just good
gathers cannot be bad else as well just
keep it just keep the position closed it
just takes jump like a son this is just
an exchange right it is still a bit a
bit messy this position but what black
should be am clearly better white is
also down to 20 seconds I doubt that
dumb I can save this again from from
your close to hopeless position like it
did in the and the game before now
probably just drooped to see eight black
group see you know now bellowed be fiber
saying after look be five from how do
you continue
yeah to get there get the King into
safety probably rookie phone
yeah this looks this looks that now
too much Knight f3 maybe this one yeah
it probably doesn't matter lots of moves
were winning Lou creator can just take
it
yeah it's just just a couple of spy
checks really this this is nothing yeah
yet this looked like a fairly fairly
good and convincing victory bio-it wow
ok the the very trendy f3 line re 66 is
a fun answer
yeah this has been played I think in in
the de Broglie brought up tournament of
course g66 and getting the Nitro h5
looks really weird I mean for for
classical player let's elect our Shore
Steinitz or some someone of that era
this must look like complete nonsense
but yeah it's interesting in 65 goes for
an instant um counter play in the center
and the night on age 5 um yeah introduce
those green age for check ideas
alright so now a six has been played and
yeah why problem needs to exchange yeah
it is 1 upon but it's not clear if this
is a good position the light squares are
really weak after the the bishop on f1
has been exchanged on b5 c6 black has
got many ideas interesting ideas may be
queen each form check with movie then
Quincy for just a five Bishop a6 is a
possibility yeah but I think g4 was also
may be a threat by white so yeah we
should f2 now maybe after Bishop f2 you
also can consider quinta form
Bishop f2 Queen fos could be good just a
techie 5 and after the exchange night F
form there's g2 hanging there's not d3
check threatened and b2 is saying so
what cannot really exchange maybe a
bishop III some is better and then Queen
a choice is a draw funny enough yeah
queen edge for draw it but I suspect
they will continue
yeah queen before black black hats no um
yeah black is not needed to he doesn't
need to make the draw you can continue
without any big problems Bishop takes e5
not probably getting the porn bag yeah I
like black in this position to be honest
the White King on the twin side can um
can be a liability
Bishop f5 as a possible post for the
bishop very nice to um um control vital
squares for white skin but this is also
good improving the night on h 5 feet he
brought it to f5 and maybe now take c5
after night to at five has basically one
in temple on the bishop p.m. make now
exchange and this looks now very nice
for black there's also night III to see
for this is a rather big threat really
oh my dear mmm interesting question how
if black now would simply exchange
Knight takes Queen takes Queen takes
rook takes this can be good for black if
you manage to avoid the pawns on d5 on
c6 being um yeah being fixed on those
those squares but this now is just an
attack right let's say Ruby a juke f2b
aid I think black is quicker here you
cannot afford h5 I mean it it shouldn't
work hmm maybe how does h5 OSD for just
a i can go d 4 of course takes g 6 ft x
juicy g6 Queen h6 just loop f7 so now d
4 wins wins apiece and like black also
should win the game I think there is no
no compensation takes on g6 yeah it
takes on if you be tied to take with the
pawn you can maybe even takes you three
but just H takes g 6 ft x g6 Queen h6
rook f7 protect
your own king and you win the the knight
on c3 yeah he went for this simple
solution just winning the light now and
now Ruby to yeah yeah this kills Quincy
three would be seven made yep very nice
wasn't really difficult i mean i guess
home or so moves but it's a them it was
rather smooth I think this some of this
opening went wrong for white this e 6 d
5 is really a fun a fun option okay
english opening with them
Oh gifty falls very very unusual night
XD for now what is why doing here this
was simply a blunder for porn or maybe
maybe maybe d4 was a mouse slip it's
also possible he wanted to go d3 which
would be here again I can go back here
g3 would be the normal mu 492 but this
simply default just blunders the porn
now d 5 and black gets it back out of
this position but this looks a la
completely ugly because now the white
square some are opened wide the should
be 65 as a possibility and white is very
very weak on the light squares at some
equal material but down look at this g3
porn if this would provide white spawned
beyond g2 then there's simply not going
on so much I mean so quite okay
no but here I think white is some scary
worse nopee should be four and Bishop e3
this is a very yeah kinda hits it very
very serious threat and white them
simply resigned yeah it's not in great
shape IAM the mysterious probably
Russian player aslp continues for a
couple of games I know from experience
of you maybe haven't played so much for
a while on an online blitz you need a
couple of games to adjust of course this
is a completely different level of play
but it's it's it's it's the same for all
players you need a bit of time to adjust
again to do to play with the mouse and
so on okay so queen dee Ford some an
interesting sideline of the pelts
defense Queen Devon it's um directly
yeah but should be five now the idea
it's a direct way to combat the c5 DC
525 line and leads to it's the
interesting play some some sometimes you
can really catch people unawares in this
line of course not those people yep but
normal let's say normal player some have
their problems Quincy for a strange we
should be five is the move that you must
play now not text and force a
possibility i recently looked at this
line this is why i know that yeah now
Queenie for bishops III is just a big
edge for black I think this is some
this probably would be a victory form
for a fellow
black some
very nicely developed and also after
taking c5 phone will have a simple extra
porn it's not not easy to take it down
right now probably place quincy form but
black can just move on and must move of
course the the bishop away from c3 and
simply has got a good game with
completely misplaced white king yeah he
even found the bishop before here
interesting
yeah Bishop before was an interesting
move I didn't expect that you somehow
i'm always think about going back on the
long diagonal but this seems much
stronger queen bee six probably and yeah
well rights king is in terrible shape
after king yeah kingly to probably king
d too long castle he's also ugly kinky
too probably yeah maybe just short
castle short castle and then looky a
drupe d8 what a disaster your wife can
can can resign this position basically
now now just long castle and roop these
six to come you got a big attack so
blame for nothing also note that there's
Queen f2 also in the position can be a
pretty good movie white let's say please
you should be three or something then
Queen f2 just wins yeah this is a very
ugly
get to strip t6 problem
hmm
intending Roxy item gas is probably very
strong it looks strong at least
and rock 260 King b8 was very strong
Luke c8 coming on a pot very big attack
just it just took took took material now
white skin is still in lots of trouble
Knight d4 maybe yeah intending rook c8
checking the Queen may I just take the
Queen Mary down and resins care white
I'm really played this this Quincy
formal this this plundered the game away
simply
yeah now an open Sicilian for a change
let's see a night off maybe I don't know
what it what plays normally so a 6 the
night off and you should be five is the
the deal would the old sharp main line
which M was completely out of fashion
for a long time but now for a while has
returned to the forefront of theory
everything focus on Bishop e3 on new six
but now Bishop g5 is back so the most
direct way to to handle the night off
this really provokes exactly this yeah
it's a it's very dangerous now I'm and
blacks problem simply as that in a blitz
game how would you get get your king out
of this sir out of this mess you never
would have a safe King position you're
here white can p.m. do you want to take
on a fade instead of long cast later
also was 95 which looked quite nice to
me not sure about this yeah maybe night
295 25 and attacking the rook okay he
wants to install this this night
probably black needs to take it at some
point it's difficult to do without yeah
I understand then the e porn is really
strong white can think about just rook
e1 + f4 attacking this night and getting
it away from the fire film post White
has got two pounds anyway for the piece
so it's a it's not a huge material
investment
now this is surprising to at least there
for me I thought white neat said the
move f42 to kick the night away but
maybe he's just intending to take e 5
and in the blacks on blacks play with
Queen d7 aw yeah Queen somewhere to f7
this this kind of ideas on I or queen d
386 but this simply am forced the King
away now look every year so as there's a
threat yeah it looks strong but before
was interesting
hmm yeah this is a very very unclear
position and hard too hard to judge with
little time of the clock
yeah okay three check just Bishop to f6
must play that yet this intense probably
look at three check and Rupert e7
yeah this is a murderous position to
defend us black even with more time on
the clock it it's very very tricky but
in in a blitz game um this is not the
task that you would associate with
having having fun at the chessboard or
in front of the the computer in this
case young white probably just wants to
take a five and continue the attack I
now Quincy five exchanges Queens ah now
this is the CEO / looked down the sea
over them
yeah after the Queen trade done like its
assembly winning
no white still has got two pawns but
okay black you should be able to
coordinate his pieces and down and win
the some windows position
yakkung f6 coming and the econ fault the
problem is that black here is not is it
it's quite ask is quite um nicely
coordinated especially the bishop on g5
on f6 it simply keeps her the hooking
side together you will win the upon
probably and white cannot really attack
the black pawns efficiently of course
why it's only drawing idea as to get rid
of all the pawns and then draw against
play a draw against the bishop look and
Bishop against single rook so what tries
to get rid of all pawns but he's simply
not able to exchange um let's say age
six and g7 this is always protected by
the night down how do you make progress
here very difficult yeah black and some
like a swinging it just it's a bit of
time to to do it he's got the increment
of one second so this should be really
enough to to win the game
threatening rookie to know
maybe Bishop g5 and rook takes h2 okay
what white tries to utilize the King
against the the Kings side at the grid
sideboard Brooke f1 maybe gap I think
black one minute she's down to eight
seconds but it's not so difficult
they're white spawns am also not not
connected yeah now you can you can
resign simply why black can just after
rookie to for example can just take on
deform and trade this down to a king and
born and game yeah an interesting game
again enter Raffaello has disconnected
simply was probably a bit disgusted by
its form it didn't really play up to the
standards 3500 years it's really really
high in this game here mostly overlooked
the Queen trade position was really
unclear be before that yeah thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed it and I
always try to get some of those cubits
videos in but it's just a matter of luck
how many or what good interesting
players to watch out on there so yeah
thanks for watching